AND YOU CAN SEE WITH FREDDDD DeR
THEY TOOK A CHANCE
14 GAMES COMING INTO TONIGHT AND
SVECHNIKOV WATCH IT, HERE IS DE.
IT WAS JACK WHO SUGGESTED
B TO THE ZEGRAS LINE WILL STAY
OUT THEN YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
SEASON. DUCKS FIND THEMSELVES
IF FOWLER BEHIND THE NET, THEE
DUCKS ICE TIME LEADER CANNOT
CLEAR AND IT TAPE.
HE JUST HAS A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
TO REALLY LOOK FOR THE LANE TO
OPENEAN IS THAT
HE'S NOT MOCK FORTH IN THE CORNF
THE ANAHEIM
ADAM HENRIQUE, FORCING THE
GOALTENDER ANDERSEN TO
>> John: GOOD LOOK AT
LINDHOLM, JUST PLUS 11 IN HIS OY
CAN REPLAY.
>> Brian: INTERESTING
AHO ELUDES THE HIT, MANSON PUTS
IT BACK DOWNE'S BEEN WHEN STICK.
GIBSON AGAIN FORCED TO COME OUT
AND PLAY SAME AND AGAIN
IT'S GIBSON WHO HAS TO POP OUT
AND KNOCK MIDDLE AND
DISRUPTED.
IF GLASS.
A GOOD CHIP BY
33 TO GO THESE TEAMS WILL NOT
PLAY AGAIN, FIRST TIME IN 22 EVN
ABOUT THAT.
I WANTE LONG PASS AND
THAT'S INTERCEPTED.
IF COUNTERING OUR THE CANES IN
HERE
AND THE ONE TIME AROUND THE
BOARDS.
SNEAKS SILFVERBERG TO
THE BENCH AS THEYHIRD PERIOD BYR
THE BEST PERIOD THE SEASON FOR
THE
15 GOALS AND 24 GAMES IN
GIBSON!D AND THE
HE STARES HIM DOWN AND DOESN'T
MOVE AND JARVIS PUMPS THE AWAY.
THAT HAD SOME KIND OF ZIP ON
LINEUP.
PROBABLY THE REASONN
MORE GOALS THAN CONNOR
McDAVID.
I WOULD SAY HE'S OFF TO A PRETTY
GOOD
>> Brian: AGAIN. IT.
SNEAKS